I have a question for you
the industry acceptance when you were
like on your Mountaintop the industry
you especially because you worked your
way up through the industry and that's
the only way to get in in the industry
you were the darling everything this guy
does is amazing groundbreaking Etc is
that addictive because after 2017 it's
not there anymore but you're still
putting out the same product the fans
still like it the same so is that
something that you feel like man [ __ ] I
missed that or is it like no I'm still
putting out the same product
so I was actually a great discovery for
me because I didn't know what it would
be like because when you're there and
we're taking private jets to do stadiums
which is kind of a grind it's not it's
not really what got me into comedy was
the big stuff and I'm also never been
comfortable with uh big Fame the big
like oh my God Fame is just it doesn't
make me feel like a per I like feeling
like a person yeah so when somebody
treats you bigger than that or less than
that both stink to me yeah it just makes
me uncomfortable I don't I can't I don't
identify with that and the industry I
knew it from I mean it's I've been doing
this for 37 years so that I was in it
long enough to know that when I was
getting a lot of acceptance from there I
was like yeah right like I know this is
short-lived I know this is conditional
yeah and I know a lot of it is just wind
you know it's not really but again it's
there's actual human beings involved I
had Partners in the industry who had
really meaningful relationships with who
I'm really grateful to like like FX yeah
I mean FX even after my series Louis is
on my website now they let me have it
yeah and I mean I paid for them I paid
them right but they did that's an
unusual thing I I they took it down from
every other service and they gave it to
me and I you could only get on my
website now that was a really great
thing and they did that for me so
there's that's a human thing to do yeah
but anyway what I found out was when I
just needed to just work again and
sometimes just comedy clubs there is
this fear when you're up there if I ever
had to just go back to the funny bone
is sitting next to the soda machine is
it out into the room the smell of fried
food what I may just have to kill myself
right if I go back but I got back there
and I was so happy yeah I loved it
because I just loved telling the [ __ ]
jokes yeah and I'm closer to the crowd
and the money you make is a stand-up
selling out a comedy club over a weekend
is ridiculous it's that it's close to my
that's enough Point yeah it's just I
mean they give you the whole [ __ ]
door yeah and it's insanely good money
so money wise I was like I can live on
that yeah I and then make it and the
fans pay less which is something that's
better for you and then when you make
and then you make and then when you get
little bumps like hey I'm back in the
theaters this is so [ __ ] fun didn't
know if I'd be back in the theaters but
it's just doing the work was plenty I
don't miss that [ __ ] at all the being
the Mountaintop a Mountaintop is a place
you visit you don't [ __ ] live there
you don't live in a tent sucking oxygen
it's actually not fun up there it's a
goal yeah but it's not a life it's a
place to visit and it's a place to be
seen from miles around so you can
collect I have fans now from a lot of
different plans all over Europe I play
all over the world
because of the opportunity I was given
by those people yeah in Hollywood to get
up high but now I've got I've there with
me I was smart enough to collect them on
my own to find a way to get directly to
them yeah did you I don't miss being
like [ __ ] red carpets and being in on
lists and that kind of stuff I think
Comics are too self-aware to enjoy that
to enjoy that stuff that like red carpet
treatment people love it a lot of them
love it some people need that they like
that's their indicator that they are
live that's their indicator that they're
going that they're doing something yeah
I think that's sad that's not that's not
sustainable and it's also not based on
you it's based on a trend I got a lot of
attention that didn't I didn't have
coming to me yeah I I'm proud of the
work I did but I'm it's got it was like
are you kidding me yeah like when I saw
Comics looking at me going like dude
enough I agreed with them I'm like I'm
sure you were it's just like it was
enough already yeah and it was like oh
you know you don't want to be that guy
right you know so there's a uh Jerry
Seinfeld to quote your boy Terry
Seinfeld was accepting an award my boy
yeah we accept the award for something I
forget what it was Peabody Ward island
or something that's a great video so
it's like the Philly birthing it was and
he's up there he goes I don't want to be
here I want to be in the back with a
bunch of comics making fun of this whole
stupid thing in the world here yeah and
yeah that's that's what you have and I
think that's what we have I mean it's
stupid the red carpet thing is dumb all
of it is done
what the [ __ ] else do you need you don't
need these Five Guys you don't need that
you don't need the Press you don't need
them saying that they're good versions
of all of that yeah it's cool to read a
review of your work that's well written
that's thoughtful that's positive sure
that feels good but I would if it's
between that and the audience getting
off on it not even the audience loving
and coming but the audience get knowing
that you're hitting them yeah then the
rest of it can go [ __ ] itself it's
meaningless I have a follow-up based on
what you said about getting your own
emails and not liking the Mountaintop
did you do that knowing I don't want to
be here for long did you do that with
like I'm getting the [ __ ] out of this
whole thing that I'm in right now I know
that people don't stay up there that's
always been clear to me so I always knew
that was temporary he said in an opiate
an Anthony interview they're like
they're like you're doing you got
private jets you got all this kind of
stuff and you're like yeah it's not
gonna last it's not a Kent yeah yeah
when I first got my show at FX which was
when I first got my show at FX John
langraff who became my friend who runs
the place he's just sent me he asked me
if I'd ever seen the shield what was
their first big success great show so he
sent me 10 it was DVDs then send me all
of the 10 seasons and I lost my mind
watching The Shield yeah yeah I watched
all 10 seasons and I was obsessed with
every character and every actor and you
can tell when they're making the show
the way they walk on the set they're
like I'm on a hit yeah I'm on a hit yeah
this I can do anything after this none
of those people are working anymore
none of them Michael Chiclets is a
monster you can't even see his face
and all those other when they were like
you know I mean some of the Walton
Goggins is like fine keeps finding work
and he's a great voice yeah but but
they're not what they were on that show
and they were winning everything and
they were all anybody was talking about
and that's not a bad story that's a good
story you get to be this shining thing
yeah but you gotta give it up you got to
be willing to give it up and Dismount
you know I was dismounted
and I'm grateful for that because I
don't know I don't know what I I don't
know what it would have been like I
don't know I did prepare for it well
that's yeah yes I did but uh but the the
trip down no matter how it's done I
think is rough it's for anybody is it
cool nobody gives it up on purpose
nobody goes like that's I've had enough
yeah only George Washington that's right